so
we i understand we have quite a mix of
people in the audience so
i'm going to try and i like to try and
tailor my conversation
conversation important word as opposed
to my talk um
with you so that you can get the most
out of it and i can give you the
undergraduate course in venture capital
and startups i can give you the graduate
course and so
i'll give try and give a little bit of
both and for some of the people that i'm
talking about things that
other people know a lot about well you
know we have a time for
questions later and like hopefully i can
answer them i was uh
at mayfield fun i was in venture capital
for 20 years in silicon valley so and i
was born and raised in palo alto
my dad's a stanford graduate of course
we're both berkeley graduates as well
from the engineering school there and so
this is like my hometown i used to sneak
into stanford stadium during the big
game
after going to being going to school at
palestine high school and saturday sneak
into the game and stuff like that
that was when the security wasn't as
good so
anyway it's gotten much better so let me
kick off and try and talk about this
interesting topic and see
what we can do probably need there you
go okay
thanks thank you so who am i i'm old
enough to be your father
my kids are probably older than you are
even though i hopefully don't look like
it
uh you can see the years i graduated
from stanford which was a long time ago
i still found my way around campus
although somebody has to tell me that
skilling
was next to duran because durand was
around when i was here some of the other
buildings weren't and even some of the
buildings i
used to go to are missing like the
german auditorium so
um anyway tournament engineering
building um i stayed too long at one
company which was mayfield
most people change jobs every four years
um i was at mayfield fund for 20 years
and so that's where i got my
uh my uh graduate degree in venture
capital
i started as an associate there and i
became managing partner
20 years later and in 2004 sort of the
tail end of my
time at mayfield fund i helped start a
a venture fund called gsr ventures at
the time in 2004 for those of you that
can think back about
what the world was like for startups and
venture capital you know 1999 2000 was
the
uh internet bust as well as the telecom
bust
and so a lot of venture capitals were
sitting around from 2000 to 2004
thinking about how
gee how are we going to get the returns
that we used to get for our limited
partners
in that time frame and and we we picked
two areas
india and china so um i think very
fortuitous at the time mayfield has an
india fund and
mayfield fund started uh gsr ventures
which would where they've acted me to do
that um so we were the first mayfield
fund was the first uh
investor in gsr ventures and eight years
later
four years later i joined gsr ventures
left mayfield fund and decided to spend
um full time with gsr ventures and in
started working more actively i go to i
i'm i actually
coincidence with that i as i told you i
was from this area
mayfield fund was based in san jose park
i lived in woodside
i moved to las vegas and i commute so i
commute here
every other week and i commute to china
six to eight times a year so
i figured why not pay lower
state taxes while i'm commuting
um you've heard about all these other
things too
a couple of notes too um 54 companies
i've invested in over those 20 years at
mayfield fund
nine that went public 15 that were
acquired that was in the days when
you know acquisitions could be just as
good as
as ipos
my most recent one which some of you in
the it industry may not know i was
chairman of the board of a
public company on the nyc called 3par
and most famously in 2010
hewlett-packard and dell fought over uh
three-part and we were
you know when we were a public company
being acquired by two public companies
everything has to be public and so it
was a quite fun public auction
and hp finally won for 2.3 billion
dollars
that division at hp by the way is still
the most profitable division at
hewlett-packard and has the highest
growth division in hewlett-packard
as hewlett-packard has fallen on
difficult times with the rest of their
businesses
okay so oops sorry
let's talk about why did
mayfield and i think about china in 2004
and i set the backdrop for you as well
it's it's really quite easy um on the
left-hand side of the
of the axis here you have the number of
deals
that were invested in now we're talking
about early stage deals early stage
venture
capital is characterized by
companies that you invest in that don't
have any revenue yet probably don't have
any product yet even
versus later stage deals okay so early
stage deals in
the from 2004 to 2010 754 in china
um 2276 in the us
um and then look at the i mean the
numbers on this side don't mean as much
in terms of the size of the dots
although it's uh
it's kind of impressive um because it's
by numbers right
the real important one which investors
care about is this number over here
because so for
9.3 billion invested from 2004 to 2010
it turned into 155 billion dollars of
of market value for companies in china
whereas in the us
you had less than return of a 1x
investment right
so that's what that that's the
significant of that okay
um so we had that backdrop clearly we
were in 2004 so we
didn't have all these numbers yet but we
saw the writing on the roll
this is a little bit unfortunately of a
of an eye chart
but it does show essentially we're
counting only billion dollar
technology meaning that companies that
exit meaning ipo or get acquired for
more than a billion dollars let's count
those
all the smaller ones let's not worry
about for now which is actually a lot
of those you make a lot of money in
those companies too but let's just focus
on those
there's 49 of them since 2003 um
in china and here's the year of ipo
here's some names that i hope
hopefully if you're in an east asia
class you recognize at least you know 10
cent and baidu and things like that
and then of course their sector and then
their market capitalization
so clearly there were some companies
that were doing
important things already which gave us
fodder for figuring out what we wanted
to do
here's a list of most valuable internet
companies in in 2005 and in
in in december 31st 2012 and look at the
list here too of um
there's no chinese companies there and
if you look here there's 10
cent alibaba and baidu that are on the
list as well it's interesting the number
spans from one to ten
you know 122 billion dollars at at
google took speedy at eight billion
dollars
fast forward to 2012 and there's google
at 232 billion dollars
and then the number 10 on the list which
you can't see because
the slide but you know baidu is there at
35 billion dollars
so clearly the chart has gone up so in
other words if you invest in the
internet sector as a basket of
investments
you still made a lot of money regardless
whether you're in china the u.s it's
just that
china has come to its fore in terms of
being able to create
large internet companies so another good
thing
this is the graduate part of of the talk
for those of you that watched the market
2011 was a
bubble peak in china in terms of tech
investing
and since then there's been some issues
with chinese ipos which i won't
go into right now but i'll mention two
words again for graduate study
something called transparency in terms
of accounting issues and the other
thing is called very you know vie or
variable accounting
a lot of issues with respect to chinese
ipos and their
market performance and their accounting
techniques were
made there was quite some stellar
revelations actually made on a couple of
companies none of them tech
companies they were all they were all
actually natural resources companies and
other chinese tech companies
but nonetheless u.s capital markets
looked at these and said oh
we don't really know what's going on in
china and so chinese ipos have had
actually been challenged
up until this year and that's what this
slide shows
that since 2013 actually the chinese
ipos have started to do better again as
confidence rebuilding just like any
other market cycle you know there's a
there's a scare there's a downfall and
then
confidence rebuilds and then the quality
companies can rise to the surface
and that's what we're having here too as
well so some companies here too vip
shops was an e-commerce company
nq mogul mobile which is actually one of
gsr's companies
um which is a a smartphone security
company
are actually performing quite well post
their ipo and why is that important
it's important because when you take a
company public and a company goes public
at ten dollars a share let's say
the public market buyers expect that
it's going to continue that growth so
they would like to have that 10
stock go to 20 stock as the company
grows and becomes more valuable
well if it does if it does go below that
it part pellet market people get upset
quite rightfully so and then they don't
invest them anymore so that's that cycle
that i was talking about
so let's go on
so this is the real chart that
for me at least in terms of convincing
my partners in mayfield
that we should be in china why we should
be there
okay so is this these numbers which i'll
go through in a second
and the other fact which is i'll always
remember in my sort of
experience from the 80s
until you know 2004 when we were making
these kinds of decisions
that if if you're in the technology
business
if you weren't looking over your
shoulder and there's a very very famous
guy
who talks about that is which andy grove
you don't haven't read his book it's a
great one
that you're looking over your shoulder
and saying who else is doing this other
than me
and at that time frame because of these
numbers
you know my observation was india and
china okay and our partnerships
uh this um observation was that as well
for those of you that remember boston in
route 128 boston route 128 used to be
you know pretty pretty competitive with
silicon valley in terms of
technology companies you know you had
companies like digital equipment
corporation
data general wang corporation these were
all companies that competed with
hewlett-packard in fact
digital equipment was beating
everybody's butt except for ibm and
they're all east coast ibm
included but i'll always remember
meeting with one of the founders of
of of a workstation company which you
won't remember
um and he said wow you know we were
building these these workstations on the
east coast and we never
thought about intel we never thought
about berkeley bsd which is
berkeley unix and what that could do to
the rest of the world so they weren't
looking over their shoulders
and what we looked at at mayfield was
wow look at this internet and mobile
growth look at what chinese the chinese
population
and market is doing in terms of internet
growth
mobile user adoption um and then you
know there's other areas like renewable
energy and automotive
automotive has been growing much more
automotive is a growth market in china
whereas here you know obviously in 2008
2009 it was not
for the us and we said look this trend
is going to continue for a long time
this is a trend that we have to
be part of on top of that at that time
most of the semiconductors were being
made in asia most of the semiconductors
were being put into products that were
being built in asia and then brought to
the u.s
when you have that kind of of uh
of of knowledge and expertise being
generated in an area
pretty soon that area begins to build on
top of that and then
create their own new products and things
like that so a lot of things were
happening there a lot of expertise and
some core strategic errors were
happening in technology
so we said if we if we're going to be in
the tech and this is the exact words
that i used when talking about it to my
partner to convince them to invest in
china was
you know if we're technology investors
and and we want to
continue to be successful in technology
we need to be in
in china and india so to me that was a
quite simple
simple things i talked about in china
very briefly and this chart shows it
this shows the amount
of vc funds meaning people like gsr
raising money from
third parties institutions and taking
that money and saying we're going to
invest that in tech startups so it's
that it's one before
going into a startup okay so this is vc
fundraising and that's a this is a
leading indicator right because
we raise the funds then we take the
funds and investment startups as
startups take five to eight years to
turn it into something valuable and then
you know some type of event right so
this is a leading indicator right
unfortunately it's also a little bit of
a lagging indicator because you look at
2011 here
there's a big bubble you know and this
is the problem with markets and timing
and things like that as well
2011 happened to be a great year when
everything in china was go go go
you know everything that you invested in
looked like it was going to be
successful there are huge markets et
cetera
and then obviously the money flows in
money has a very fast velocity
right money flows into areas where
there's returns
and if you know your macroeconomics what
happens there right so
this is what happened in 2011. um
china went through some of these issues
as i mentioned before um it's now i
think stabilized now china's sort of
stabilized
in terms of the the companies you know
expectations are kind of meeting
um reality in terms of what's happening
and so
so things are returning back to normal
so 2012 actually is a more normal level
and actually for a venture capitalist we
like this better
because you know if there's just if
everybody's making money
no matter where you put it you know we
have no value added
right but we know over the long term
that that can't be true
and in fact um we like to have these
types of levels in terms of the
investments if you look at this number
on in 2012
what does that say nine billion dollars
that's a little more sustainable level
people
in our business if you're a venture
capitalist looking at your economics and
you're looking at your
your world you're saying what's the
amount of dollars that this startup
world or the startup environment can
handle before it gets overdone
right how many you know times can you
invest in
multiple facebooks and get a return
before you know no one's successful
right
so that dilution happens so that's
always
a level that we that we seek
this is just i'll skip over this this is
fundraising by type
there is a in china
and originally how gsr started if we
raised
dollar denominated funds in order to
invest in chinese companies
in china there are limitations on
foreign currency conversion
and so this is the mechanism that we
invested in
what's becoming a trend has been sort of
started about three to four years ago
is investing in rmb which is the local
currency denominated funds
and so you raise rmb funds to invest in
chinese companies in rmb
there's it's it's too complex to go into
right now
but there is this extra world that
exists between
dollar or foreign currency dynamic funds
and r b denominated funds
that you don't have here in the us
because there's you know free
free currency translation and stuff like
that there's no restrictions
except for the patriarch act
um uh this is a this is another uh um
and she tried can will these be posted
on the on the course website
yesterday some of these i decided to put
in just so that you guys could have them
as referenced as well because if you
ever want to do any more research or
look at them
these are numbers from quoted sources
that you can see below
and anything you ask about in terms of
you know how much money is flowing into
venture capital in china how much money
is being invested in what industries
you know these kinds of numbers
uh are here for you but let's get on to
the more fun stuff
gsr ventures and this is a little bit of
a sales pitch but i'll go through it
really quickly let's talk about venture
capital just as a asset class and as a
practice okay
mayfield fund was founded in 1968 by a
gentleman by the name of tommy davis
he started in venture capital in 1963.
and for those of you that remember a
company called watkins johnson which was
also a stanford spin-out like
hewlett-packard was stanford spin out it
was you know stanford students
with the support of frederick turman
starting a company at stanford
industrial park it was one of those so
tommy davis was an investor that was one
of his first investments was in 1963.
and he had a firm uh with a gentleman by
the name of arthur rock who's legendary
in this area
he most famous he invested in intel
and also they invested in xerox
scientific data systems which became
xerox which became xerox park
so that was their early days of
investing in 1963 in 1968
tommy started tommy davis started
mayfield fund
which is where where i was so by the
time i started in 1988
mayfield was already 20 years old okay
the characterization of venture capital
sort of
up until 2000 was it was dominated by
a class of very top-tier vc funds and
over and over again we continued we
may feel being one of them continued to
to outperform the group and there was a
very
very select group 2000 kind of changed
that the internet bubble as well as
other things sort of changed that and i
would say that the success across
venture funds became much more broad
now that took you know some 40 years
okay in china which you know
a fund cycle is maybe a third
of what the us typically is
has accelerated that and taken that
40-year history and compressed it in a
much
shorter time frame and there's a good
reason would you would you uh explain
what you mean by fund cycle oh fun cycle
sorry
a fun when you raise a fund like let's
say we raise 100 million okay we're all
going to go out and
we're going to go to limited partners
we're going to raise 100 million dollars
to invest in the startups
that hundred million dollars gets
invested over a certain amount of time
and that's what i would call a fun cycle
typically that number is four years
okay and then after we invest all that
we go to the partners again and say hey
look what we did
give us another 100 million dollars
we'll take another four years to do that
i mean
there's a lot of details in between of
course but that's roughly how it goes
in china of course china has the
opportunity in all markets
whether they're electronic markets or
whether they're vc funds that it has the
past experience of
other places to look at and so
everything's everybody knows a story
right that's sort of
what it could become and so the cycles
are much quicker and i'd say
in general in china all markets again
happen that way very quickly
okay we'll talk more this last one talks
about sort of china versus the u.s in
terms of the differences i have a slide
specifically about that so i'll expand
on that more
okay so we're focused on a very specific
there's many
types of venture capital i already
talked about early stage
uh venture capital so gsr and mayfield
fund where i was
my experience is an early stage venture
capital meaning
it's typically before you have a product
or typical and certainly before you have
revenue
okay you have a bunch of people they
have a business plan they have a
powerpoint presentation
and they want to raise money to do
something and and we we choose to do
that or not
we have 50 active portfolio companies
meaning that we've invested in them
their their their outcome is yet to be
determined that's what i mean is by
active
since 2004 and this may look like a
small number and
we've had two ipos and one mergers and
acquisition meaning one company was
acquired
so net chin is the number the company
that went public um
that's in the smartphone business we
have one that went public actually on
the shanghai stock exchange which we
wasn't weren't expecting it's a it's a
bloomberg type company called
called dadzuway and then we had a
company that was acquired by
a majority acquired by baidu and it's a
for those who know the kayak china is
the
chinese version of kayak very simple
vertical search okay
very successful company we still have an
ownership of the company
uh one of the founding partners of of
gsr ventures richard lim is still on the
board and uh
it's a it's it's a great company doing
very very well
okay so when you're in
when you're in early stage venture
capital
there's many strategies of course and
the strategies
that we have chosen to invest in which
is my experience as well in mayfield
is to invest in early stage companies
that can be huge companies
so we're not looking if you okay for
those of you that are baseball fans
there's batting average and there's
slugging percentage right
so read money ball um
great book uh batting average is great
you know uh you bout 400.
slugging percentage of how many home
runs and multiple base hits
that you have right and so in our form
of venture capital this happens to be
one form
we only want to invest in companies that
can be billion dollar outcomes you don't
always get there but we always want to
invest in
companies that have potential for large
outcomes
so what that means is you know risk
reward
that means we have a lot of companies
that don't make it
we have a lot but but the few companies
there's a very famous saying in venture
capital it says you can lose your money
once okay it was actually
read dennis he said you can lose a
million dollars once but you can make it
back many times
and what do you mean by that if i've
invested a million dollars in a
mobile game company if it goes bust and
i lose all that i
lose that million dollars however
if that game company turns into zynga
i can easily make back 10 million
dollars off of that
million dollars so that's what that term
is very very read dennis is one of the
i want to call him grandfather i hate
that but um
he is a grandfather so i mean he's one
of the grandfathers of venture capital
and very famous thing he had another
very famous saying too it says cassius
king i mean that was read dennis as well
too
so anyway um that's what we're looking
at and the sectors we invest in internet
software
wireless green technology
systems and components okay
we have carried the strategy
consistently over
our eight years of existence we have a
very stable team it's the same
same team and even at you know um
even at eight years old we're still a
very young firm
you know by young i mean that even
though we've raised four funds
with a billion dollars under management
there's still many cycles this team as a
group has to experience right
you know spend 20 years in venture
capital and maybe you get
you know two or four cycles if you're
lucky
and the more cycles you have just like
the turns on a semiconductor or
how many times how many revs on us on a
software version you have the more turns
you have
it gets better every time right so it's
tough to be good on just one term
okay what does it take to succeed as a
venture capitalist so so
i think most of you guys want to be
entrepreneurs but the postgraduate of
entrepreneurs is being a venture
capitalist and for those of you that
aspire to that which
when i was sitting in your seats i did
you know i was
i i my vision was to become a venture
capitalist after i became a successful
startup entrepreneur
this is which i mean it's actually quite
simple you have to be good at investing
and make money if you're limited
partners that's that's all this says
one of the problems however is this darn
feedback cycle we talked about the fund
cycle being four years
you know you could be a venture
capitalist for five years and you have
no idea if you're any good
at it or not because the companies
you've invested in at early stage you
have no idea how they're going to turn
out you could have one
that does return money and you could
that could be luck
but how can you be sure that you can do
that over and over again so this is the
this long feedback cycle is one of the
issues about
being a venture capitalist which makes
it hard everybody that
i you know i used to meet that you know
was
in your shoes or other shoes that wanted
to be a venture capitalist they go wow i
want to be a venture it looks so easy
you know you guys make so much money and
blah blah blah
everybody every one of those actually
made in venture capital when i speak to
them now they go wow you didn't tell me
it was this hard
because you don't see everybody sees the
successes you don't see all the failures
okay what does it take to succeed as an
entrepreneur
well to me the number one is vision
and the vision is to me simply put is
this
is what the world will be like after me
after i do this this is what the world
will look like
okay now this is a big vision too this
is the billion dollar type company right
because
this is not like well i'm gonna make it
easier to get into your car i'm not
going to make it easier to do this
this is about how the world is going to
look differently after me
okay it takes balance
extremely difficult this is something
that nobody ever gets right and
if you're any good at yourself at
bettering yourself
you work every day to try to do which is
how do i find the balance
the balance is what's my strength of
condition that's what drives you to do
something
that says this is the way it's going to
be dart it and i have a vision darn it
right number one
versus wow i better listen to some
people that have some opinions that
count
and some of those opinions are terrible
and some of those opinions are very good
and you've got to mix those two and find
that balance so that this is a
this to me is extremely hard too but
necessary criteria
um there are a few people that damn
their torpedoes i don't care about
anybody's opinions and they are right
but it's usually they're usually
listening somehow
whether it's their gut or whether it's
their closest advisor whether it's their
wife or
whomever it is they're bored of drugs
hopefully
so the other thing too is uh
this this is a i i i kind of you know
everybody's heard of the book failure is
not an option right
so definitely and this is a old chinese
saying too failure is an opportunity
right and no fear of failure
this is a very societal thing before
china and and i remember in the
in the 90s i used to get invited to
countries and say how can we have
silicon valley what do we need to
develop silicon valley
what kind of infrastructure do we need
to put in place and
you know i'd i'd tell some of them like
i remember going to hong kong and
speaking at the china club
and they said what can we do to get that
and the answer to me was
you know societally you
you know some societies have this issue
about failure right whether they call it
what do you call it loss of face or
failure or whatever some places and by
the way this happened to be the east
coast too for a while on the us
i tried to recruit a friend of mine
long-term friend of mine who's who's a
vice president digital equipment
corporation to come come to the
come to the valley to take a job where i
thought he could do a great job and he
goes oh my neighborhood would never
never look me in the face right if i
said i was leaving digital equipment to
go work at a startup and so
i think i'm crazy right so cultural
things not just
you know us versus china or things like
that made a big difference and many
cultures are like this
where there's there's you know the
failure is seen as a black one
i think in china and other countries
like israel there is this issue
about you know trying one's best is
is good enough i mean not all chinese
culture is this way i'm not certainly no
expert on it
but certainly the people that i hang
around with in china don't care about
failure
i mean not of course they care about
failure but they
they don't care what long term they say
i can do it again i can do something
again
okay so this failure not an option thing
too is
that's the period with this balance
right if failure is not an option
sometimes it's better to go home and
start
over again than it is to just bowl
through something and i can't tell you
where that
point is but you know the failure not is
not an option thing is great
if you're on you know apollo 13 and you
have literally no other options right
but if you're doing other things
sometimes it's better to to to do that
to change to change um resourcefulness
good network of people
i think these are all things you know
and of course money we'll talk more
about that of course
what does money mean so now we're
getting into the section about what's
sort of different
sort of lessons for me 20 years in
silicon valley eight years in china
what are some differences and these are
the difference that i found
about raising venture capital
so um basically none
right good people great value
proposition
great market you got to be able to
communicate
no idea is worthwhile if you can't
communicate it to someone else
and then you of course have to email our
linkedin me in order to
get funded um or you get it from friends
and family or you find other
other vcs so let's talk about this is
sort of fun but it's true i i stand by
this even though it's a little
tongue-in-cheek i stand by this so let's
let's dig a little deeper what does this
mean so it's different in china
number one i had a little bit of issue
with in terms of as i wrote it because
i believe it's true but it's also i
think i couldn't decide whether it was a
major factor or as a result of something
else but
but clearly that has this has to do with
the fact that you know the people
networks there
are not as large and harder to get in in
contact with
if you're in silicon valley i mean you
go to downtown palo alto at starbucks
and you can find someone to figure out
how to do something about a startup
right
or you go to your next-door neighbor you
go to your classmate or you go to your
dorm mate or someone
there's information all over the place
now clearly with the internet
that a lot of that is is is gone as well
and in fact in china
that's how a lot of entrepreneurs and
people get their information about how
to do things and that's you know one of
the wonderful things about the internet
right
but the other issue is that even if you
still need people you can find and read
as much as you can but at some point in
time you want to be able to talk to
someone who's done it before
and that's what's missing in china now
there is a starbucks in china that's
like that
for those of you that's almost like the
downtown university avenue starbucks
right
it's in jungle and chun it's it's where
chingua university is and there's
electronics
and sort of high-tech park all around
chiang mai university and there's a
starbucks
in one of these markets for those of you
from japan
when i used to live there's akihabara
remember akihabara i think it's still
sort of the same way i remember it
but they're in in joganton there's still
an area like that
and that starbucks i mean i can sit in
that starbucks and i can run into people
that are you know from the valley and
all over the place it's kind of fun
actually
um so um again this is related to what i
was just saying as a point point number
one
um it's it is incredibly hard to find
good ceos chief financial officers
engineering managers you know you find
some specific engineering disciplines
it's hard to find people in china
they're there
but they're hard to find and if they are
there they're extremely competitive if
i mean if i didn't care where i lived
and i was a cfo and i had
experience bringing you know you know
being a cfo at startups or taking
companies public
i could make twice as much money in
china as i could here right now
because it's just that hard as a talent
to find
there's not that many people here with
sarbanes-oxics i mean in china with
someone's oxy experience or
or with uh public uh accounting
practices and things like that i mean
those are just
hard hard to find people and in fact
much
like happened during the bubble here
there's people that jump around from
successful company to successful company
and are doing quite well for themselves
um in key technical areas like if you're
experienced in mobile at all mobile
advertising or mobile e-commerce
those people are in very high demand in
china right now hard to find
um the tribal knowledge uh do people we
know what i mean what i mean
tribal knowledge i'm trying to say sort
of like the generally accepted knowledge
that
sort of people around you sort of know
palo alto
is a you know or silicon valley in
general is kind of just a weird
different place right again
if you want if you went down to i mean i
remember speaking at my kids
economics class in high school at gun
high school which is on foothill road in
rossidero in palo alto
and some kid in the audience asked me
about
preferred stock versus common stock
it blew my mind i just couldn't believe
that i don't think there's any place in
the world you know it has to
obviously do with the environment we're
in here that someone did that
i think that person was very smart but
you know
that specific knowledge um they're in
in certain areas in china it's getting
to be that way as well but uh
um the tribal knowledge is sort of
what's around and where you can get that
here you can get that knowledge
by talking to a neighbor classmate or
it's just easy to find
right and in china it's still not there
are lots of groups that meet
entrepreneurs that meet and things like
that and it's pretty cool because those
are getting uh
uh pretty active as well in fact
stanford and alumni association berkeley
and stanford and alumni associations are
actually
very strong rallying points for people
to get together and talking about these
things too so
the tribal knowledge is increasing
support infrastructure is hard you know
i mean here
landlords understand if you can't pay
them you want to give them some stock
options
along with the rent they're willing to
rent you even though your company has no
history whatsoever
you know places in china i mean you go
to the government they'll understand
that but
no one else will right so just little
things like that
you know i need a cad designer i need to
do some industrial design
i mean i can just go to any place around
here and find an industrial design shop
or
consultant and they'll do that for me
right china it's a little harder to do
that
okay there's a smaller number of
experienced people like me in china as
well too
a lot of people in china vcs themselves
don't come from operating backgrounds
and aren't necessarily
and think from the mind of an investor
versus the mind of a venture capitalist
and
venture capitalists are investors but
they're more
operating people and technology people
than they are pure investors okay
you need use of both of course
on the plus side i think it's well first
of all it is
you know you can prove it empirically
it's cheaper to do business in china
but the other thing i think it's easier
to do business in china
and it has to do with the environment
with the government and with the
general population i think you know
silicon valley prior to the bubble burst
was wow i'll try it anything can work
let's see whereas today it's more like
oh what's going to
happen on the downside how can i protect
myself from something failing
whereas in china it's like wow let's try
that let's see if it works
i think people are more i mean just the
general population like for
example smartphones innovations and
smartphones innovations in personal
technology
people are much more willing to take
chances on it whereas
i think in the us it's not quite that as
well either and part of it is because
the general population is increasing in
its exposure to
things that are more than just basic and
so they're open to all kinds of things
like that it's like a kid with a new toy
so disposable income is a new toy
entertainment
and being able to have income to spend
on entertainment to buy a car
to buy a smartphone to buy the next
generation smartphone to try something
else i mean a new tablet
i mean that's all there okay
so what else is different china so what
are the implications of some of the
things we're talking about as well
and here's i think for those of you that
are that are
already china watchers my number one
thing that's different about silicon
valley versus china right now and
the basic challenge for china
and so that's
changing and adding to the management
teams we already talked about the
shortage of management talent in china
okay but in silicon valley
it's change it if it isn't working right
which includes ceo which includes vp of
engineering which includes
you know up and down the ranks you find
someone that works at it it is a very
darwinian system here right you either
make it work or you don't or you hire
someone else
if that you're not going to be able to
do it in china it's not
quite that easy right whether it's
because of founders whether it's because
of allegiances of teams
or whether it's just because of lack of
talent whether it's cultural
there's a lot of those things and so in
in china
i think this is going to be the number
one thing is um
i i'm a big believer in this thing is
change is good change is your friend i
also believe
is that you know there's an old sports
saying if something you're doing isn't
working
you change it it's better than doing the
same thing over and over again right
and so in china i think from the
management side
people have to get comfortable with that
it's a it's um
i think and again i'm not a chinese
cultural expert but just my
observation is that it comes from the
fact that a lot of successful
chinese companies were were either
government or patriarchal
right patriarchal meaning that there was
a family business and it was run like a
family with the
with the patriarch on down right and so
how can you replace that right the owner
and the ceo and the chairman are all the
same people
right well this is different western
style businesses
startup style businesses are ownership
and leadership
are separated leadership and this is the
difference between us
traditional business and venture capital
two is that u.s leadership has a large
stake in the ownership of the company
but does not own all the company enough
to control it as well so that check and
balance is a very i think
is very real you can theorize about all
day you know people the business school
can write
write all kinds of things about
executive compensation and motivation
and things like that
in real life this is how i've seen it
played out and that's my personal
opinion
i think it's a key ingredient of success
what i just described
about silicon valley okay
so the bottom line when i talk to
entrepreneurs that are in this position
and we've only had one situation maybe a
couple
where we've successfully changed
leadership
um is do you want to be successful or do
you want to or do you want to protect
your ego
that's what it comes down to at the end
of the day right
even someone is revered as steve jobs
failed his first time around as ceo of
apple and i would say fail
he grew a lot did a lot of amazing
things and not taking anything away from
him
but and then he could come back to apple
and do amazing things
absolutely unbelievable things right so
different people at different phases of
their lives are good at different things
and very few people last from the very
beginning in the garage
all the way up to a hundred billion
dollar company or even a billion dollar
company
okay so on the other things about china
that are different liquidity events
m a is a very common here started in the
90s
before the 90s in silicon valley
technology m a's were not
uh as apparent um in china
it's a very new thing there's one of our
companies that i told you about china
got bought
by baidu that was a very new thing in
the internet space
i mean there's a lot of 5 million and 10
million acquisitions but this was a 300
million dollar acquisition by baidu
there was a merger one of uh the
founding partners of
of gsr is the chairman and founder of a
company called asia info
asia info did a multi-billion dollar
merger with with uh
linkage and that is a i mean that was
unusual too so those things are still
new
you know obviously in the silicon valley
over the last 20 years since the 90s
we've had many many of those things that
have been successful
capital market strategy difference um
the china factor i talked about which is
the transparency in vie
i won't go into those right now unless
there's questions about that later on
so how you approach an ipo in china is
just a little bit different as well
we already talked about the first one
in china because it's easier to get
started and actually do more with less
a lot of the early stage startups and
i'm going to contradict myself a little
bit actually have
product or customers already even though
they've gotten no institutional funding
it's because you can do a lot especially
the types of business obviously doing a
mobile game company
or doing an internet company is is takes
a lot less than if you're starting a
semiconductor company or an enterprise
software company or a networking company
as a result we have we have more time to
choose deals because there's just fewer
vcs there
um we have found the relationships with
the central and provincial governments
to be
very very positive i mean unbelievably
positive
i mean the chinese government lays it
out so well about okay here's our 10
objectives that we're going to do for
the
for the next the next five year plan
and if you follow those i mean it's it's
not like changing administrations and
things like that where things can change
overnight right
so it's very it's very reliable and also
they're well thought out as well i mean
they're very common sense strategic
areas
um china has taken a chapter out of how
japan developed itself how korea
developed itself how taiwan developed
itself
how the u.s developed itself and has
combined all those things
so there's no it's no no surprise that
there are science parks here right
everybody has copied the
stanford industrial park model right
it's a very successful model all the way
from shinchu in in in taiwan to
you know uh chingua and and uh jungkook
in in in beijing so um so anyway so
that's
it's it's it's it's really really good
um translating experience from silicon
valley china takes experience
um clearly you just i mean i would say
for the initial five years of our
company
of gsr ventures when we invested in
companies it was you know like you saw
china was sort of the chinese version of
kayak we could do that in many different
things we had to translate it
but we could do that with many different
things we've learned a lot about what
translation you have to make
kayaking and china are not exactly the
same company sort of same
spirit and the same ideas but things
have to be different and
and in in a chinese way and that's
that's our experience that we've that's
what we've learned over the
over eight years so so you know so we're
not talking about language translation
we're talking about business model
translation and
and um it works really well there are
also fewer and fewer things right as you
go over time because
as the chinese entrepreneurs have caught
up with the there's less lag between
what
innovation gets done here in the
internet space or
e-commerce space or the coupon space and
then when it gets translated in china it
gets
copied much faster there are other
markets where that
that experience is not there um
e-commerce has been a little bit slower
but happening but different in china
you know there's many other areas where
there's some fascinating things that are
happening in terms of differences
um so a couple examples gaming
there's no con there's basically i mean
console games here of course are a
mainstay of gaming
in in the us in china there's no gaming
consoles everything is pc or
online or mobile okay
the in china there are actually
and this is an area where the the
knowledge of business models can go the
other way
the modernization for gaming in china is
much more well developed than in the us
i mean 10 cent
is a company you know the largest
internet company on there except
yeah for um in terms of chinese internet
company
has made its initial money completely on
monetization
on things like virtual goods and things
like that unbelievable fantastic company
and they're i they have a development
center in in silicon valley and palo
alto now
on the mobile side mobile i think this
is an area where china is
is is on par or leading compared to the
u.s
mobile gaming i mean due to the fact
that there's so many mobile phones and
very rapid mobile adoption in china and
plus the infrastructure in terms of lte
and
and 4g networks and things like that
happen very quickly in china
um those there's exploding growth there
so the
the interface between internet and
mobile is uh is incredible
um there are some things that too china
mobile has i don't know what the number
is like 80
market share right so imagine one of the
carriers in the u.s having 80
market share it changes some things a
little bit um distribution and payment
there isn't i mean
the itunes does not dominate in china
this way same way it is here android's a
very effective
platform in china monetization is an
issue so
um so there's some issues there about
how you actually
monetize and things like that i'm going
very slow we've got to go fast
i'm behind okay there's smartphones we
talked about that
ios revenue growth freemium is the model
you guys know the difference between
freemium premium models on gaming
freemium is definitely the way to go
um i won't go into this too
this has to do with the fact that that
applications and who controls i mean
there is no apple store there is no
google play store there that is dominant
it's all fragmented in china right now
and
believe it or not too china mobile is a
dominant carry there really doesn't
provide much direction either too so
that app whole app
universe is kind of strange in china
right now
the successful companies are making
money off of itunes stores for chinese
you know chinese applications and there
are so you know successful
uh developers on the uh on the android
world but it's not consolidated at all
it's more fragmented
um one market that doesn't exist is
that's been existence and very
successful for venture capital and
startups in
in silicon valley is enterprise and
software infrastructure
it's just been non-existent in china now
for lots of reasons that we can go into
clean tech is is huge in china as right
now we're sort of in a downside in the
us in terms of
material science and clean tech
investing in china it's huge
the government is supporting it it's one
of the when it plans electric vehicles
for example batteries
that whole area is is a huge area of
support leds
where gsr happens to be large investors
we're investors in electric vehicles
batteries and
and leds you know all due to government
direction and support and initiatives
and um opportunity um in the stem getter
side
i mean starting a seminar here company
in silicon valley is just tough in china
it's it's still possible in selective
areas we have some very successful
semiconductor companies actually
oops that's it so sorry i had to rush at
the end a little bit though but i'm
running out of tyrann at a time here and
wanted to make sure that i left time for
questions sorry
yeah that's great we've still got some
time for questions
so let me ask the first one um did you
see
the reduction in in vc funding in 2012
as a correction
is it going to move back up now or is
this something related to the slowdown
in the chinese
no no so first of all i think you know
again there's lots of different beliefs
that
um everything moves in cycles and i
believe that
2012 will be sort of the bottom of the
u-curve meaning it's going to be flat
for a while and maybe
you know could go up but it's it's it's
not dropping anymore things are
things are in pretty good shape in china
okay good let's move on go ahead
cycles are faster in china and it would
seem like
uh for venture capital it's a certain
type of investing it would seem that it
would be
the same if you shorten it too much
you're basically flipping
and if it's too long then it's not vc
investment so why would it be shorter or
do you mean that they're overlapping
more or what you mean exactly
so it's a good it's a great question um
the time it takes from investing to a
company to the time it's mature and
maybe
successful is actually looking about the
same
i mean the us now for us venture capital
portfolio companies it's about eight
years which is
actually a long time for our chinese
companies if you look at our short
history at gsr
it's six to eight years as well you know
and so
from that perspective it's the same what
i mean by shortening cycle
i think more about market and technology
cycles
and maybe even more market cycles okay
so for example um when groupon remember
those days when groupon was hot and the
next big thing
right so that cycle actually happened
fairly fast here in the us meaning that
there was a big hype it got big very i
mean groupon got
big in revenues very very fast and then
it quickly dropped off and flattened and
became out of favor right well in china
there were probably 500 groupon
knockoffs
and they went through that same cycle
that groupon went through
with only maybe a six month to a one
year
lag in terms of time so that's that's
what i meant so
so there's a couple of different themes
sort of playing there
um and now the the the groupon
sort of uh fad in china is still there
and probably will be successful not as
as big as we thought it would be but um
but it's morphing you know and it's
morphing very fast
i mean 500 startups like that too most
of those were junk right that
you know weren't that good but so is
the gap between domestic vc and and
foreign vc
shrinking is domestic vc really becoming
more like we would know vc
and silicon valley yeah yeah so the i
would claim that
most of the foreign vcs are still a
dominant form
in in china in certain industries like
the same industries we would consider
here
i mean there are chinese vcs and certain
other industries that
us based originated vcs don't
participate in and stuff like that
but in general i think the the usbc's
are still okay that's all one over there
at the engineering talent over here is
definitely
way more there's way more here than
china however
china obviously has a huge market so
what advice would you give to startups
that are
starting here but targeting the chinese
consumer market
so i i think that uh the way i don't
have to repeat the questions are there
that's all right they should be picking
them up so um
i i i so first of all i i do believe
that we will
mature into a world where um
you know uh talent on both sides of the
world
will be the same we have a lot of
companies that actually have feet in
both places being
development organizations in one place
or the other just like
you know it was popular have silicon
valley companies have an indian
development arm
many of our companies are thinking
globally now first
i mean ideally would be great to have
more talent in china but
you know people are are
are developing in both places so there
is a there is a possibility of
creating a company here for targeting
chinese chinese markets
so how do you bootstrap the same way
that you would bootstrap any other
company i mean
we have gsr has offices here and in
beijing
now initially it's mostly because we're
funneling talent that's
was coming from you know u.s companies
and universities going back to china
that's why we have an office here
but more and more it's because we think
that there can be you know
talent in both places it's always hard
though to have
i don't care where you're in the world
you are it's not just the china u.s
thing though
it's always hard to develop for a market
when you're actually not in that market
you know i mean you do have to be
careful of that
good go ahead well through this seminar
richard has taught us
a cultural difference about
entrepreneurs in asia that asian
entrepreneurs oftentimes prefer to
start a business that they can pass on
to their kids
their kids will inherit it so how do you
sort of separate
the folks that are have traditional
thinking culturally uh versus the
more silicon valley type engineering so
once an example so
so like richard i mean i you know
i lived in japan as well as um you know
for the first part of my
early tech career you know obviously a
lot of business was
japanese-centric and i'd say that was
more prevalent in japan
and in hong kong in china
because of the background i mean
certainly it has that
culturally but it's it's it's it's it's
it and it's true in some industries but
the industries that we practice in is
less true because
they're not historical businesses right
when you order a real estate business or
in a manufacturing business
doing textile manufacturing or something
like that maybe you have
more of those um so taiwan and hong kong
are characterized those
when i mentioned patriarchal type of
sort of management experience
that's what i was referring to though i
mean that was that sort of cultural
artifact
yeah so you're talking about the ability
to change
management or ad management to a chinese
company
and this is something that the venture
capitalists here have been very
effective at to aim for maximum growth
right is that because the
ownership shares of stock are typically
lower for vcs
in china so that the original owner
founder has
more stock or why is it that the
dynamics don't allow
change as much that's it
it's a very it's a very good question i
i i think some of what you said is true
and
but it's you know my experience to date
is that it sort of depends i mean do the
founders have more shares than
than i don't think the answer is no i
mean but i'd have to look out
statistically to really firmly answer
that mic
do you have a way of looking at a at a
group ahead of time
and seeing ah this group is not going to
listen to feedback
uh we we like to think so
but you discover more as the
relationship goes on
but it's it's just hard i mean i mean
it's not easy here either it's just uh
um
how do you do what is due diligence in
china due diligence is the same as is
here i mean yeah i mean
there's no difference in due diligence i
mean we still talk to the same
kind of networks of technical experts
that you would talk to to sort of check
out the technology you talk to markets
you talk to customers
and then you just interview the people
and get a feeling for the for the people
themselves i mean
ideally if they were again i mean we can
do a little bit of personal do those and
say
because usually someone else knows that
other person in china
it's some of that is happening but so
some of it is less too so it's it's it's
it's hard
but that's true of any market that
you're going to for the first time not
just in
china so it is a fascinating issue to me
bruce personally
about this issue of control and changing
management and things like that it has
happened
you know um um in china we have done it
um and you know but it's it's hard and
also it's teams
there's some teams that are just
absolutely loyal to their their managers
that they have there and then
and then so if you change that manager's
like oh my god yeah was it going to do
yeah okay while i'm still asking have
you seen a shift
over the last eight years in terms of
new areas of opportunity
you know labor costs are higher now so a
lot of the old labor cost difference is
not
going to be an advantage yeah so i mean
that's another
point i don't think things that so our
business tended not to be
based on lower cost labor lower cost
manufacturing yes
which in some cases has to do with cost
of capital okay
but not just pure labor cost it's
usually for
the investments that we've made is lower
cost of capital and lower manufacturing
costs and so there are some
areas we invested in where we do count
on the fact that either scale or
lower cost of capital means lower
manufacturing costs okay couple i saw
your hand first
how do you deal with intellectual
property issues
both in terms of how you make decisions
in china
and uh how you see that changing as
we're moving forward
so a couple of things i was never a big
ip person even when i was in silicon
valley i mean
you know entrepreneurs were usually more
scared of people stealing their ideas
than i was because
it's usually if you're investing in a
company it's about know-how right as you
always hear at ip there's there's
there's the intellectual property and
the and the and the copyright protection
and there's the know-how right know
how's a big portion
i mean the software included as well
there are some areas of course where you
cloned something
i mean if i shouldn't i don't know if i
should say this might be politically
correct but if you're like huawei in
you know 10 years ago and you're
literally copying
firmware out of cisco's routers you know
i mean
both sides say that doesn't happen that
didn't happen right but anyway so
um that's why it says politically
incorrect but anyway
you know that's that's one thing i don't
think that level of copying is is a
problem in china anymore because
china has evolved not only in the wto
process but also now china has things to
protect every time you have things to
protect you start protecting other
people's things and
it happened in japan it happened in
taiwan you know
happened in the u.s can i drill down on
that just a minute just by mentioning
that the average cost of litigating
an intellectual property case is
somewhere around three to six million
dollars
and most startup companies can't afford
it
here or anywhere else right yeah yeah
yeah i saw another hand
go ahead yep you were next yeah
you mentioned that gsr has a great
relationship
relationship with the presidential
government in china um
so i actually heard like different
stories between either these the foreign
vcs with the government or the
entrepreneurs
with governments so like it's actually
not that nice
they're like some nasty stories i just
want to get your point of view on like
well those nasty stories are other
people of course
no i mean what so if i
led people to think that we have special
relationships
that's not the case the relationships
i mean again not to be politically
correct
i mean you you know in china there's a
big problem of course still
with who you know and who you're related
to
and how you can get things done we have
never been one of those firms that
depended on those quote unquote
relationship deals
okay so that's one type of relationship
right the son of the
ex-prime minister you know whatever the
case may be right
we don't like those deals in fact deals
that had some kind of special
relationship or some
license at all most of them have not
turned out very well
so the relationships where we've
actually built a good just like you
would with a a
a a government in terms of bringing jobs
in an area and they provide you
you know you know tax holidays and
things like that
or land in order to do that i mean those
deals have worked out really well
because we have the same mutual interest
and i'd say our government relations on
that
measured by that scale are very very
good
the provinces are very anxious
especially some of the second-tier
provinces to bring
technology and jobs into their areas
into certain areas and they've targeted
certain areas
so for example we've started a
healthcare initiative there you know
there there are many science products
that are very focused on healthcare and
biotech and biopharma
you know there are some that are focused
on
solar some are focused on leds some are
focused on battery technology and we've
had
enjoyed really great relationships with
those of course they can go wrong
you know luckily we weren't in chongqing
for example and you know
at the wrong time but uh um
go ahead
i know that's like law or content is not
that
good it's not that good and we know that
in john quincean district we will have
some
uh organization like innovation works
they will give some
law and a content support
so what do you think is uh what do you
think uh the differences between the vc
and the traditional vc and this kind of
organization i mean like
specifically innovation works model for
example
or or for example that if we want to
have vie
structure and you know there are so many
terms actually
that is very difficult to understand yes
and also uh
for a company at a very early stage it's
very hard for them to hire very
professional
yes yeah so how to solve those problems
so so just to expand on the question as
i understand it so other people can
i can follow um um
in order to get foreign money into a
chinese company
meaning u.s dollars these vie structures
were set up which are very complex
take very professional people to set up
you have to get permission from the uh
the chinese finance commission for for
lack of a better a better name for them
in order to do this and it's a very uh
it's a tough process it actually makes
it harder for for
for startups to be very fluid if you
have a structure like that so
i i totally agree with you and i think
that is the case
i talked about r b based funds if you
have an r b based fund where it's r b
dollars that you're investing
it eliminates a lot of those issues
however
it provides tougher problems on the back
end when you get to be successful
because r b
based investments have to go public on
domestic exchanges
this all has to do with the current
foreign currency exchange controls that
the chinese government has
i personally believe that in the next 10
years
i wish i could be more accurate and i
think it's personally shorter than that
those those issues will go away you know
because
it's it'll be beneficial i mean the
chinese government has had very good
reasons
i don't want to become political again
too about having a foreign currency
exchange controls
in this particular you know it has a
much bigger backdrop of why it's there
in this small area of startups and
things like that it is a big problem and
i think that's going to be taken care of
over time
we are very good at setting up the the
vi structures so it's not
you know um we do that as part of our
services and stuff like that as well
so excellent i saw your hand
how many investments was 50 companies so
i'm wondering so how many companies are
biotech
related and where day one
we just started and today is only one
after two years of setting up
this practice there's only one and it's
not a biotech it's a medical device
company
yeah but we we are interested in in
biotech and biopharma companies so so
where
are the bc bad companies located mainly
on beijing shanghai or
so um our first one is actually um
we have a model also too where we invest
in u.s technologies to bring over to
china
so our first one that actually is u.s
technology that we want to bring into
china
and biopharma companies that will also
probably be an example
where we'll do that as well we're
looking at one biopharma company that's
based in silicon valley
but its market is probably 100 in uh
in china due to many facts due to many
factors i mean
it couldn't be more targeted on it
because it's only for han chinese
one of the you know apparent strengths
of silicon valley
has been that we have a lot of people
from everywhere who live here
and one of the patterns that i've seen
over the last 10 or 15 years are people
who
grew up in china and they went to school
here and they worked here for a while
and then they want to go back and and
start something in china again
you have any special advice for them
well that's why we have a silicon valley
palo alto office is because the
i mean our our initial model eight years
ago was to take advantage of those
those people yeah and actually what we
found out it's kind of interesting for
people that have been away from china
too long like 15 or 20 years
they go back in china they may have
family there but they don't have the
networks of
of um of tech workers that they would
have
current current networks right um so
that takes a little bit of adjustment
then there's the people that are here
for four years for the phd pro and then
go back and they're very current
we love we love build types and we can
facilitate that
i don't know if you you realize too but
that government
chinese government actually has a
beijing provincial city government
actually has
money that they will give you to
relocate back to china if you've
come from china originally i mean so
there's lots of easy ways for people to
do that and and we can be very
uh useful in helping people get back
okay
go ahead as we know that in recent
months
the china the chinese economy is slowing
down
and someone even say that the euro has
it growth is over
and it it says that the
the government the central government
needs to
provide providers some state-owned
sectors
like this soe like china mob as you
mentioned
so in your perspective where this
happened and if this happened what will
be the impact for the uh let's see
well i think china like any other large
country
and prosperous country has me has many
issues um
i've i've i have many things to complain
about
the chinese government as i have to
complain about the us government it's
just hard
and nobody likes the government in power
but you know actually
in china it's it's um i guess it's the
predictability and the stability
actually
that is actually i think
better than in the us and um
even with the change in leadership there
is everybody has that little bit of uh
of uh concern about what's actually
going to happen once
the the new leaders are in place but
then you you know but then it happens
and
things get back to normal in terms of
the actual economy itself i think the
chinese economy is doing quite well they
have some major problems
ahead of them um concerned about
inflation and
and and wealth distribution and and
things like that and
and jobs just in general but um i don't
see their priorities with this new
administration changing i do
like the new leadership is focusing a
lot on on cleaning up government
um i mean i don't know if people have
seen it one of the major things in
beijing is
there's a lot of military license plates
on car on vehicles that
allow special privilege for those people
well the
the central government has decided now
that the that the
military vehicles are all getting new
license plates so everybody had old ones
that had were taking advantage of
privileges when they couldn't
you know are going to be left in the
lurch and stuff like that so i mean
we call that symbolic or not actually i
don't think it's that symbolic i think
it's pretty
pretty real but i think i think the the
new leadership is focused on on doing
something right i don't think there's
going to be a lot of changes to soes
in the near future though to that
specific points last question
do you see from the purely business
standpoint a changing
role for hong kong or taiwan or
singapore that have been kind of jumping
off places to china
so let's see um like they're not going
to be needed anymore
so okay so yeah no well no no i think so
first of all taiwan provides a lot of
tech management expertise in china yeah
and there's a lot of
taiwanese management expertise that's
that's in china has been there for
20 years or more so i think that's going
to continue
um as long as the relationships between
taiwan and china are the way they are
now
there's been some minor bumps it's great
i could live with that status quo for a
long time
um the question is with will china want
to
increase that i i can't say i can't say
that i don't know
well and i'm really sticking to the
business yeah well no that's going to
affect the business side of the
relationship
okay so so it's just as far as hong kong
goes
hong kong i think is a gem that china
recognizes but it's a gem with
some problems right the problems so
first of all it's a financial center
i think the chinese government loves
hong kong as a financial center
unfortunately if that includes money
laundering that's terrible right no no
no seriously i mean you know whether
it's
hong kong real estate or other things as
well
singapore continues to be a great
destination for plan b
for a lot of people and so for people
that don't know plan b
is i mean china has not been stable for
all that long and the wealth that's been
created there people don't have the same
feeling stability that we have here in
the u.s or in europe
and people are always in the back of
their mind thinking about their kids
and the stability of and protection of
their family and
wealth and so people that can afford it
have a have a plan b
maybe whether that's you know their kids
going to school here or
being born here or having a citizen
moving their citizenship to china
singapore is playing a big role in that
right now the same way that european and
eastern european wealth is flowing to
singapore because switzerland is
now not the best place in the world so i
i'm not trying to make this a china u.s
thing but singapore
is becoming a haven for that and
so that it plays a big role as well but
hong kong is going to have a fantastic
role in the future of china
okay i'm afraid that we're out of our
regular time but we've got some
refreshments outside
let me ask you to let's talk with our
speaker outside not in here okay
so thank you very much again great
fantastic